we are going to put added pressure on
this D5 square and develop our Knight
here to
B3 a lot of times black will respond
developing to F6 putting pressure on the
E4 Square so he now has two attackers on
the E4 square and we have one Defender
and normally here we want to before we
move this Pawn we want to go ahead and
get our Bishop out of the way and the
whites for why the light Square Bishop
is usually it's more powerful Bishop so
we're going to go ahead and use our dark
Square bishop and pin down this Knight
here um this will allow us if we want to
move this Pawn one we definitely can
build a nice little Pawn structure where
our light Square Bishop can move around
freely uh but you definitely want to get
this bishop out first